il est mentionné que la classe politique
était un monde de bisounours qui avait
dit vous n'êtes tout juste devenir la
clé on vous avait déclenché l'hystérie
que vous
alors madame oui jeudi qu' un certain
nombre de gouvernements sont ali face
aux problématiques de l'immigration
c'est ce que j'appelle le monde de
bisounours
j'ai connu des injures plus grave quand
même que celle là bon mais quand on
était à grenay injure non division c'est
le concept qui consiste à considérer que
tout va bien que tout est merveilleux
qu'il y aura jamais aucun problème alors
que moi je dis qu'il y a des problèmes
que c'est vous mêmes peuvent s'aggraver
oui mais que les mêmes causes en train
de les mêmes effets sa selle et vous la
sagesse populaire l'attelage cas
savez-vous lebel parce que je vois bien
ce qui s'est passé enfants notamment au
québec
je vois bien ce que je vois bien la
dérive du communautarisme qui gré comme
partout d'ailleurs parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'exception comme partout des
revendication politico-religieuse de
plus en plus importantes auxquelles une
partie des québécois avec lesquelles une
partie des québécois sont en désaccord
voilà j'expose mes idées politiques
madame je suis et nuit je suis à la tête
alors du premier parti de france